-Our first guest tonight is th
Emmy- and Peabody-winning host
of HBO's "Last Week Tonight.
You can stream
the seventh season s--
seventh season on HBO.
John, I'm going to show yo
the cue card Wally wrote.
He wrote "season" twice.
On HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend John Oliver.
-Hello, there.
-Give me that card, Wally.
John heard that
and I want him to see.
Now, again, I should have know
not to say "season" twice,
but I do want you to see.
-Sure, but you went full
Ron Burgundy, and we just --
The only thing you're guilty o
is trusting Wally too much
[ Laughter ]
-It's true.
-And on that point,
you are guilty of murder.
[ Laughter ]
-How are you, my friend?
-You know, alright.
-You're in, again --
I talked about how jealous I a
that you cracked early on
to shoot your show in a void
-That's right.
-And then we all came back
and you stayed in the void
-Nope.
-You love the void.
-I love it.
I love the emotional
antiseptic atmosphere
that this void provides.
It also lets nothing in.
Nothing -- Nothing from my life.
It's just a completely
sterile environment.
-You did have
a fantastic season finale.
You blew up 2016,
four years ago.
-Yes. Yes.
-And then this year,
you blew up 2020, which,
arguably, deserved it more
-Yes.
-Which is hard to believe.
-Which is why we went with a
significantly bigger explosion
-And how does it go --
how does it come about
when you're trying to figure out
how to have a bigger explosion
-Well, it was --
literally, it was just askin
explosives experts, saying, "How
would you make this bigger?"
And they would kind of go,
"Hmm, I don't know.
I guess a lot of gasoline.
That makes sense.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not even sure you needed
to be an expert to say,
"Just more gasoline,"
and that's basically it.
That's how explosions work
But yes, we went and did tha
in a quarry in New York,
and it was absolutely amazing.
It was an utterly staggering -
I was a little bit cocky,
having done it four years ago.
I said to the guy -- He said
"Look, this is going to be
really big
and it's going to be loud.
I said, "Yeah, you said that
four years ago
and it wasn't that bad."
And he looked at me
with total contempt and said
"Yeah, this ain't
four years ago."
[ Laughter ]
So then it happened, and h
said, to his credit, he said
"Look, this is going to --
it's going to feel very ho
and then for about
a second and a half,
you're going to feel
like you're on fire."
[ Laughter ]
And he was right about that.
And that second and a half
felt long.
Because you get to a second,
you think, "I definitely feel --
I don't have a point of
reference, but this,
I feel pretty on fuego
right now.
And then they were all
really, really impressed
I didn't flinch, to the poin
that they were so surprised,
it became actively hurtful
Just one after one,
"I can't believe it!
I can't believe --"
not even -- not even --
They even went to the monito
afterwards, saying, "Look!
They're gathered around.
"Look, he didn't! He didn't!
As if -- I guess when you
present as a coward so much,
it leaves you
with a lot of upside
for courage
because people expect so little.
They were all on the edge.
It's like, "I expected you
to just curl up, like,
in a fetal position.
You didn't cry once!"
[ Laughter ]
"Like the child we anticipat
that you are inside."
-I was very impressed as well.
Knowing you were physicall
there, I was very impressed.
-It was loud. I was very brave
I deserved a "wollipop"
and I didn't get one.
[ Laughter ]
-I might have --
I might have gone fetal,
and I'm embarrassed to say it,
if we were about to embark o
four more years of
covering a Trump presidency.
And we texted a little bit
You actually got to be the first
show post the election call,
which was on a Saturday.
-Yeah.
-And you got to do that show -
-When we were texting, I was
about to go and do rehearsal
And yeah, you said to me
something like,
"I honestly haven't though
about what I'd do if he won.
And I had not --
Until you sent that text,
I hadn't thought about it
either.
And it really was -- There i
no more joyful feeling tha
the sound of a bullet whizzing
past your ear, is there?
[ Laughter ]
-How was it? Was it --
-Everything smells better,
food tastes better, yeah.
-We've talked in the past abou
how people will say,
"Oh, my God, the Trump era, th
comedy writes itself," which..
-Mm-hmm.
-...neither you or I would -
-They do [bleep] say that,
don't they, Seth?
[ Laughter ]
-They still say it.
-They do [bleep] say that.
They do say that.
If they were trying to hurt you,
it wouldn't matter as much
Then you would internalize
say, "Oh, you want to be me.
You said something that
you know distresses me.
Congratulations."
It's the genuine question that
pisses me off far, far more,
and you know
it's coming a lot now.
-Well, you do seem well-equipped
for the next era because -
And I mean this sincerely.
You've done such
a good job of finding
insanely depressing things
that have nothing to do
with Donald Trump
over the years.
-Yeah. There's so many of them
-And there's still
plenty of that.
-There are so many
gigantic systemic problems
that I cannot w--
we had genuinely one of
the happiest moments
I've had this year, as being -
at the end of last week,
we were talking to research,
and we were going through
stories for the upcoming year,
and there was such
a smorgasbord of human misery,
just a bunch of subjects
that no one in their right min
would try
and make comedy out of.
And I just felt great thinking
"This is -- This is --
Look at what we're going t
be able to --"
it's -- I think that's why i
feeds into how frustrating it is
when people say, "This must have
been fun writing for Trump."
Because it's basically lik
saying to the residents of
Elm Street, "You're going to
miss Freddy Krueger, aren't you?
What are you going to
dream about now?"
I don't know. Anything else!
[ Laughter ]
Literally,
my imagination can run
the gamut of human experience.
No, I'm not going to miss
Freddy, you [bleep] [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
-We'll be right back
with more from John Oliver